[موسيقى]
يقول إنه قال العديد من الأثينيون الجديد الخاص بك
ماكومبا هادية لا هوبرت
وننقل كارول العربي في فلسطين
والبروفيسور إدوارد سي وتسويق السيارات
عندما كنا سبع أكاديمية واحدة في
ذلك الوقت كانت
دراسة نابينا عندما كانوا بالتأكيد سيد هان
بين  محاولة أو pohela boishakh
Phil kitabi الآخر tilma سيدي بطريقة متداولة
امرأة فظيعة
تسمى جيدا السنة لأجمل
الأعمال د.  مقود رؤية إدوارد
مرتبط ماما ويمكنني مشاهدة
كولومبيا catasleep el mal يعني Wilma
مع Madison Oh
Fallon وهي سلطة في التواضع تعرف ما
هي إحدى الضواحي التي سيؤسسها ما شاء الله الله
أن الشخص يمكنه الحصول على
غناء جامايكي خاص لـ
tikkun olam Anisha أجعل توم  القادة الذين يجب
إزالتهم سعداء حقًا ، لقد جعلتني في
الواقع ، هل يمكن
أن تكون ماشا قد أتينا للتوقف عن
التنصت عبر الابن المتقلب ، ستتكيف جاكي مع
ماجنين عندما ترى فيليب
سيطرة فعلية مع زوجها ، انظر
كلما الله لماذا لا يستطيع
وصلت بشكل متهور إلى جامعة ستانفورد وكان لديه
بعض المراجع الثقافية لأنه جاء إلى
هنا عندما كان عمره 14 عامًا وكان يحب أن
يذهب مثل Dairy Queen
ويأكل الهوت دوج أنت تعرف أشياء كانت
أمريكية تمامًا وبسبب
وجود روح بشرية
ولكنك تعرف ثقافيًا  من نواح كثيرة
كان عربيًا جدًا وأعتقد أنه كان
منفصلاً جدًا عن الشرق الأوسط
حتى أواخر الستينيات ، أصبح الموساد
مدينتنا ، نعم ، لقد
رآني حرفيًا  سأكون كما لو كنت في
مستشفى ولن يتم التخلص من
أناليما يمكن أن تعاني أنا نفسي بسبب ما لا يفعله
المصقولة حقًا في فالهالا ،
لذلك استغرق الأمر 50-100 cxeh cxeh ذكيًا
يمكن أن يغلقك تعرف توفير الحياة على ما أعتقد
من نواح كثيرة بلدي  كانت والدتي هي الشخص الذي
ربطته بالمكان الفعلي مرة أخرى
مما ساعده على أن يصبح أكثر
ارتباطًا بفلسطين كمكان
وهذا هو السبب في أنه كان قادرًا على العودة إلى
المنفى [الموسيقى]. وقائع ولادتي
بعيدة جدًا وغريبة يجب أن  تتحدث عن
شخص سمعت عنه بدلاً من
شخص أعرفه الناصرة
، بلدة والدتي القدس ، صور والدي التي
أراها لهذه الأماكن
تعرض اليوم نفس المنتجات المعروضة
بنفس الطريقة الوفيرة بلا مبالاة في
نفس الحالات الخشبية الخشنة التي يسير فيها نفس الأشخاص من
خلال النظر  في نفس الملصقات
والحلي التي تخفي نفس الأسرار
بحثًا عن نفس الأرباح
، الملذات والأهداف مثل القليل
الذي يمكنني تذكره حقًا عن
القدس والناصرة
تتمتع
بمتانة غير قابلة للاختزال للذكريات المرئية أو السمعية الملموسة
التي لا تتنازل عن أي شيء للوقت
القليل الذي لا يتم الخلط بينه وبين
الصور التي رأيتها أو المشاهد التي
لمحتها في أماكن أخرى من العالم العربي.
ذكريات غامضة عن
آخر قصة فلسطين لا يمكن روايتها
بسلاسة ،
بدلاً من ذلك ، فإن الماضي مثل الحاضر يقدم
فقط الأحداث والمصادفات ،
لذا يرجى محاولة تربية
أسرة في المنفى ، كيف فعل كيف قام
بزراعة السند أخذ الأشياء التي
كان  في الواقع متحمسون لما كنا
أطفالًا هناك لم يكن موجودًا
ولم يذهب ، لذلك ذهبنا كعائلة في عام 1992
وكانت رحلته الأولى
للعودة وهي تقارب أوليفيا
راجالا وكذلك في الكتاب إذا  لا يمكنني تطبيق
هذه الفكرة وعلى وجه الخصوص سارة تومي
فيليسيا a lavash نسخة إيما كيم جونغمان من
إصدار التخفيف المنطقي
وقد تحولت بعد ذلك بعد أن
يحصل العملاء على أعلى مستوى للحيوان  ffles
a lambda إرم الله يسلم الله inavaja
jailbait maitika الفلسفة قلب أوليفيا
لهجة أعلى FC Anatomy de-feet osteo me
Kamiya اتبع لتدفق
حرف العلة جنيفر الأب إلى آنا سنايدر سيضيف في NFC حرفًا
متحركًا إلى رهينة أخرى في التحرير حيث
كان لدي هوس السيفون القدرة على العيش
هذا غير مسموع سعيدًا لأن جسديًا
وحنين في عواء توارد خواطر
النخبة الأخيرة كانت تقييمات مجتمعنا صعبة
بالنسبة لألبرت الموتا ، لذلك
تم تسميتنا بشكل فظيع في منطقة تركيز منى
و PCR في CFM كافية انظر
المد والجزر هذا هو تاريخنا وهو  يبقى
سواء أحبوا ذلك أو حاولوا
نسيانه أم لا حظًا يا ابني برج ها
ها ها
لقد جئت لأفعل بلطف أتيت إلى هنا ها ها ها ها
نعم المهمة ومع ذلك تسمح لتقدم ماما إذا
كان الرجل يمكنه الحصول على الوظيفة التي
يمكنها إظهار أو إظهار باراك أوباما  وكان هذا
كثيرًا لا ، لم يكن يريد الذهاب إلى
الداخل ،
لكن كيف أثرت عليه تلك الرحلة عندما
أقول جيدًا من ناحية ، لقد جعلته
أكثر إثارة للاهتمام
والعودة واستمر في الذهاب إلى البكالوريا  k حتى نهاية
الحياة التي أعتقد أنها كانت
شيئًا مهمًا حدث لأنه بدأ
بالفعل في إلقاء محاضرات باللغة العربية
والكتابة باللغة العربية ، وفي الحقيقة وبعد ذلك
سيبدأ في العودة بشكل أكثر تقنيًا
على 31 a مايكل أعتقد أنك شجاع Fe
helices في  العام الجديد ،
ما الذي قالته بافي ، أنا طفل يبلغ
من العمر 32 عامًا على وجه الخصوص Majesty wahoo
في الواقع أنا الطريق السريع 50 وماذا
تعتقد أنه يريد هذا الاتصال إذا كان الأمر
ممتعًا بشكل ملكي ، أعتقد أن
هناك شيئًا واحدًا لا يعرفه الناس
عني  أبي في حد ذاته هو أنني عرفت
أنه متعاطف للغاية ونوعًا ما إذا كان
شخص آخر يبكي كما
لو كان يعلم أنه يمكنه التعبير
عن أفكاره على موقع youtube باللغة الإنجليزية المناسبة
وتقديم حجة لنا ولكن عندما شعر
أنني  أعتقد أنه كان هناك الكثير من
الارتباط العاطفي وأنه ليس عادلاً مثل
خدمة الأشخاص وكان هناك
بالطبع اتصال هناك كان هناك
أشخاص واعتقد أنه حصل على
ميزة كان لديه
[موسيقى]
أوه تحية للبيوسيل  ver
وكان والدي أكثر شهرة في أمريكا
هناك ، لم يعرف أحد من أنت هناك الآن ،
لكنهم فعلوا ذلك ، لكننا فزنا بهذا الرجل ، لذلك
كنت أعظم سأقول أن Shakalu اللامع
لم يكن يعرف Savin Philistine
زرًا مزيفًا بعد ذلك  أنت شامان مليء
ببلنغ موريان إيليسم تحاول الإجابة على
سؤال لماذا عندما نفكر في
الشرق الأوسط على سبيل المثال ، لدينا
فكرة مسبقة عن نوع
الأشخاص الذين يعيشون هناك وما يعتقدون كيف
يتصرفون على الرغم من أننا ربما لم
نكن هناك أبدًا  أو حتى التقينا بأي شخص
من هناك بشكل عام ،
يسأل الاستشراق كيف يمكننا
فهم الغرباء الذين يبدون
مختلفين عنا بحكم
لون بشرتهم ،
فإن الحجة المركزية للاستشراق هي
أن الطريقة التي نكتسب بها هذه المعرفة
ليست بريئة هدفهم  لكن
النتيجة النهائية للعملية التي تعكس
مصالح معينة هي أنها ذات دوافع عالية على
وجه التحديد يقول سعيد
أن الطريقة التي تتبعها أوروبا الغربية في الولايات المتحدة.
ينظر إلى دول
وشعوب الشرق الأوسط من خلال عدسة
تشوه الواقع الفعلي لتلك
الأماكن وأولئك الذين يسميهم هذه
العدسة التي من خلالها نرى أن جزءًا من
الاستشراق العالمي يستقبل القوميين إدوارد نزاروف
الأحداث المصغرة في استدعاء القمر.
قضية الديون الجانبية للأطفال
وأساطير تينيريف ،
يحضر محمد رام الله دا هاي ديدي
بعد رحلة Rev واحدة كفريق واحد يعني
أن هارلم يتمتع بصحة جيدة ، ويمكن أن يتمنى محمد علي أن
يتمنى بريدجيت بالتأكيد أنه
جاء إلى هنا ليقوم
بمكاتب ويلموت في المنامة في مدينة بليزا حيث يوجد
أي شيء أو أي شيء.  عالم بشري ولكن
فجأة رجل بينما كان لديّ
كافيًا مشؤومًا ، فأنت تعلم أنك تتناول لحم خنزير وضحكها واضح كما تعلم تقلق العمة ليزين
عندما ذهبت إلى المدرسة ، تمت قراءتها في
فصول الأدب ، كانت تكتب
فصلًا للبوذية تمت قراءتها في
تاريخ الفن  يمكن للفصل أن يمارس الجنس هناك ،
لكنني كنت قد جرحته لم أكن سعيدًا ، لا شيء
هذه الحقيقة هي
الغرابة الصغيرة المفضلة
لدي ، والدي هو أم أنه كتب الاستشراق
عن الشرق والغرب وهو من
القدس ولكنه من القدس الغربية
وكل شخص كنت مثله ولكنك
عربي أنت من القدس الشرقية كما لو كنت
من القدس الغربية و  ثم
والدتي لبنانية من بيروت
ومسيحية لكنها من المنطقة الغربية
رفضوا أن تنتقل أسرتها
إلى الشرق عندما
كان الشرق مخصصًا للمسيحيين ، لذلك لدي
عائلتي المسيحية على الجانب الإسلامي
من الطريق.  الأسرة العربية على
الجانب الإسرائيلي من نحن لسنا
ملائمين للقواعد على أي حال
، وبعد ذلك كان والداي يربيانني على
الجانب الغربي من نيويورك ويرسلاني إلى
المدرسة على الجانب الشرقي ونحن نحاول دائمًا
أن نكون كذلك  الجميع
وكأنك في المكان الخطأ ، فأنت في المكان الخطأ.
ويبدو أن هذا قد ضاع ، فما هي
هويتك التي أريد أن أسألك عنها لا
مشكلة مع هوياتنا العديدة
مثل أن بهرامي فلسطيني
أنا أميركي أنا عربي أنيل جوليتا
كانت في فيلا دي لا كونيجا
املأني القلبية عبد الله صاحب  eheh la raza
tomaten anal muta هل أطعمت
آسفًا بشدّة جيل موشاشا دي لا
كاناني وتامي ليسيهولر شاي باهيا
[موسيقى]
كيف تحسبين التوفيق بين
كونك الابنة ولكنك ستقول
أنه يجب أن تكون دائمًا يقظًا منذ حوالي 50 عامًا
ذهبت إلى حدث ما  وكانوا قد
وصلوني وكان لونه أحمر وكنت
برتقالية صاعدة والفتيات يعجبهن ما يقرأه شعرك يا
ابنتي وأنت لا تعرف
أنه من المفترض أن يكون نوفوستي كانيف
أحمر وكنت أحب لماذا أعرف
أنه حقًا  يعني أن هناك فكرة مفادها أن
الفلسطيني يعني شيئًا محددًا للغاية
[موسيقى]
أتذكر عندما كنت تخبرني سونيا
عن كيف كنت أبًا تم
تمثيله في الواقع عندما رأينا
صورة ، نعم ، يمكنني أن أشعر ، نعم ، ما الذي التقطته
ربما كان ذلك قبل حوالي 10
سنوات ، كانت هناك جامعة في سان
فرانسيسكو ، نفس الشيء بالنسبة لبوابات العدالة التي
تأخذ الجامعة في نهاية اللوحة الجدارية ،
قاموا برسم لوحة جدارية لأبي واستخدام
جدارية جميلة ووضعوا كافيرًا
حول كتفيه وأمي و
ضحكت وقلت أوه إذا رأى أنه
سيكون منزعجًا ولذا ارتجفت نوعًا ما
لأنني عرفت أنه سيكون مثل
لماذا أرتدي هذا الشيء في تلك
الصورة ، فليس الأمر كما لو أنه يقول ، أنا
لست مزارعًا ، إنه فقط  إن قول ما
لم أرتديه أبدًا وارتداء هذا
لا يجعلني فلسطينيًا ، ولا
يجعلني ناشطة ، ولا يعني ذلك أنني
لا أفعل ذلك ، فهو لا يحب ارتدائها ،
إنه ليس بأسلوبه ، لقد كان مهتمًا أكثر
في ارتداء ملابسه ، نعم ،
هناك تذهب ، نعم ، نعم ، لأنه كان ،
أعني أن والدي كان جزئيًا من الناطقين بالأنجلوفون ،
لكنه أيضًا أحب الأفكار التي كان تايلور في
Savile Row وكان يحب فكرة أنه
كان يرتدي ملابس جميلة حقًا
وأعتقد أنه  لم تكن أبدًا قديمة جدًا وليست
قديمة الطراز ولكن هكذا v
يبدو التويد بشكل خاص نوعًا ما يبدو بريطانيًا جدًا ، فقد
كان والدي يدخن الغليون ، لذلك
اعتاد أن تكون غليونه هنا مقالة ، لقد توقف عن
التدخين في نهاية مرضه
، فلن يريدوا منه أن
يشم ، ثم بدأ بالتدخين
السيجار الذي لا يبدأ وبالطبع
ربما أحب أن أجمع الأشياء ، لذلك كان
لديه المئات والمئات من الأقلام
والمئات والمئات من الأنابيب
والمئات والمئات من الألعاب وكان الأمر
مشابهًا جدًا عندما أراد شيئًا وحيدًا
مثل شيء ما  ستجمع أكبر عدد
ممكن
من فيلسوف البنزين لإدواردو ،
هوندا موتورز ، القذافي محمد ،
السخرية ، مرحباً أيها اللعين يا فيوريلا حتى
النصر ، أبريل ها المتأنق ، عبر صحيفة نيويورك
تايمز ، أدخل الشارب الأصفر ،
كتب جدولك العام
آرون من مجموع سمك
التوفي الثعلبة الإلهية  مرحبًا يا نجم تاهو بشكل علني
يكون مخدرًا في شجيرة أوكلاهومان
صوت هولي روكو بيلفر يضحك جيري يضحك
أكتا كم من العمل في اليوم ما كان هذا
والدي في ماتون مرقتي  كنت أنا
وأنا دائمًا نضحك لأنه بدا حقًا
وكأنه كان يتحدث على الهاتف
طوال اليوم ، لكنه كان ينتج بطريقة
ما 20 دولارًا في الأسبوع ،
وكان يستيقظ في حوالي الساعة الخامسة
صباحًا ، وأعتقد أنه تم إنجاز الكثير
في  أول ساعتين من اليوم
ولكن الجميع كانوا نائمين ، إنه نوع من
العام الآخر
[موسيقى]
إنه مدفع Hedrick honey فاطمة حريصة
على ليلة أمس في الساعة 8:00
طفل سكين صغير حاد هي كمبوديا أن
الطعام نعم من بوذا ثم سأفعل
كن مطرقة ،
يجب أن يكونوا في متناول اليد إذا
اشترينا زجاجة ماء من بائع نقانق
كان مصريًا وأنت تعلم أن والدي
نشأ في القاهرة ويحب التحدث باللغة
المصرية وأنت تعرف
روح الدعابة وستكون كذلك  لا
أفهم أبدًا ما كانوا يفعلونه ،
لكنه بدأ يتحدث إلى بائع الهوت دوج
المرن ثم نتحدث ونتحدث
ونضحك وأبي الذي ما زلت
معي يضحك أنه سيبدأ في البكاء
لأنه ضحك بشدة لقد كان
رائعاً وهو  فقط يجلس ويجلس
فقط  الذروة المصرية ويكون سعيدًا وبعد ذلك
سيذهب كما لو كان صداقات مع
الجميع إذا ذهب إلى متجر المال
لشراء شيء ما سيصبح الرجل في المتجر
أفضل صديق له
أوه آلان الذي رأى إسحاق تمامًا فرم suey
تعديلًا إدانة الشيف إنها هي
عطلة قال ماكين إنها عبء
للعديد من الطلقات الصغيرة أدي
كينيث تضحك أطنانًا ثقيلة أو LLL
طعنها ودرة أكثر مبتذلة من
أن تنجح في تعديلها ، نقول إن سالي كانت ترى
أمي تستخدم أحيانًا لتقول إن
لديها ثلاثة أطفال كان والدي يشبه نوعًا ما  كان
صبيًا صغيرًا مؤذًا أحيانًا
وكان سخيفًا معنا ولكن نعم نعم لقد
كان جيدًا بشكل مثير للاهتمام
، كان الأب الأكثر حبًا ومرحًا ورائعًا ، ولكن
أيضًا تمامًا مثل هل يمكن أن تعرف
من حيث درجاتنا ومثلما تعلم أنه كان
دائمًا داعمًا حقًا  حول أننا كنا
رائعين ورائعين ، لكنه كان
ينتقد الكثير من الأشياء والكثير من
الناس وحول الدجاجة التي تقودني
معه ، فلدينا ضرورة
كبيرة لمحمود الثاني.
إنه منهجي في لندن تم
ذيله في شخص يكره جاي وموسينا
فانيسا بيلا L ، يمكننا أن نرى
MIB له ذلك الطاهي الذي كان
طاهًا رائعًا ورجل محترم ليس
للنساء نجمة هوكي فلة بيلا 15s إرين
أوكيف  ruddy لذا ، نعم ، انظر ، أعتقد أن
النقطة الرئيسية هي إذا كنت تريد التفاوض
على نوع من السلام مع العدالة ،
فلا يمكنك التشريع مسبقًا من سيمثل
من يمثل الموقف الإسرائيلي
وموقف ADL هو
أننا لا يحق لنا فقط تقرير ما
للحديث عنه ولكننا سنقرر من نتحدث إليه
الآن ، فالفلسطينيون لديهم
ممثلوهم الخاصون ، وهذا لم يعثروا أبدًا
على أي شخص لم يعثر على أي ممثلين آخرين ،
لذا فإن دولة السلطة
باستثناء منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية الآن لا نقول إننا
لن  التحدث إلى الحكومة الإسرائيلية
لأنهم لا أعني بعد كل شيء
أن الحكومة الإسرائيلية هي التي
جردت الفلسطينيين من ممتلكاتهم التي
دمرت لبنان عام 1982 تقتل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مطرقة
- فيلا السيد.  لين عمدة
ماهابهارات أو العمدة تلفزيون حقيقي
لا يمكن أن يكون بخير كيف يمكن لطفل ضخم استخدام
الجهاد في صحة نيفادا حتى أن الكثير من أوماها
أصبح سنًا هائلاً يمكن تشويشها
على سامبا وأتيت حرة خبي
حدثنا ميليشيا  من لا يستطيع إنهاء تومين
هو لويس لو موكلا ها ياني
الممثل نينا تمتم أنه ينقل كمية
ذرية أعلى بكثير من الدواء ولكن حتى يتمكن من
ديمون إيرول ، لماذا
أدانوا وستكون مثل المرض الذي تعرفه
مع آدم ، مرحبا ديفاكي طعامي الصحي -
نحن لا نخفي السيليكون بقراءة
السجل المجوف بحرية ،
إنه مزيج غير عادي من
لغات ومذاهب الأعراق
نيويورك فريدة من نوعها بسبب
سكان نيويورك وأفضل مكان لمقابلتهم
هو في الشوارع
[موسيقى]
ما كانت علاقته بالمدينة
التي  كان يحب نيويورك
لأنه كان مكانًا لا يوجد فيه أي
شخص هنا في المنفى حقًا ،
وأعتقد أن هذا هو سبب شعورك بالسعادة هنا
كما تعلم إذا كنت تأخذ القطار إلى
حي بروكلين في بروكلين
الآن أو إلى Qu  لن
ترى شخصًا أبيض واحدًا تعرف ما أعنيه ، لذلك
هناك مجتمعات من المهاجرين في
كل مكان وأعتقد أنه شعر أن
هذا المكان كان ينتمي إليه لأنه
لم يعتقد أحد حقًا أننا
جزء ثقافي جدًا من الجديد  يورك وكان
لديهم الكثير من الأصدقاء وحفلات العشاء
والأشياء التي تعرفها كما قيل أنها تداخلت
مع الكثير من الاختلاف ، لذلك كانوا
مثل الأدب والسينما
والتلفزيون والصحفيين ، ثم كان هناك مثل
أصدقائه في كولومبيا.  أنا
وأصدقائه العرب ، لذلك كان لدينا الكثير من
العوالم الصغيرة التي يتناسب معها حقًا في
العديد من الأماكن المختلفة ، ولم يكن
هناك ما يمكن أن تقوله عنه
بالنسبة لي ، كما تعلمون أن بعض أصدقائه كانوا
يتحدثون العربية معه فقط وبعضهم
كانوا أساتذة إنجليزيين  لم يتحدث
معه أبدًا عن فلسطين أو الشرق الأوسط
أو تعلم أنه سيكون الأشخاص الذين
زاروها جيدًا ، لا توجد وظائف بالتأكيد ، غاري
مات كريستوفر هيتشنز ، لقد
كان صديقًا حميميًا ولكنه قام بتشغيل الأمر
المثير للاهتمام  سمعت جيدًا أنك تعلم أنك
تعرف كل هؤلاء الأشخاص من
المعهد الفرنسي لرفض موته ، أعني
أنه شعب نعم ، لذلك
لم يكن هيتشنز مشهورًا
، أعني أنه عرفه بعد أن أصبح مشهورًا
عندما أصبح يمينًا لذلك كان
يسارًا للغاية  - قام هو وأبي
بتأليف كتاب معًا بعنوان
مزج الضحايا عن فلسطين أم
وكان دائمًا هنا يشرب الويسكي
ويلصق سجائره وعشاء أمي
، ثم فجأة
انقلب على والدي وأصبح
يمينيًا حقًا  ثم أصبح
رجلاً مشهورًا ظهر على التلفزيون ومع ذلك كنت مثل
أوه ، كنت أعرف كريس فرانتز كما لو كنت أعرفه
طوال حياتي عندما لم يكن أحد يعلم أنه كان
يؤذي والدي
كثيرًا وأصدقاءه المقربين جدًا وقد آذى
والدي كثيرًا  سأترك
الأمر على هذا النحو مثل النجاح الذي تم تحقيقه ، إنه ليس مجرد فشل تلقائي يجب أن
يتم بناؤه ، لذلك
كان هناك ذهاب إلى أخي وأنا في كل
مرة كان يظهر فيها على التلفزيون ، نتناوب عليك
أن تذهب  في سيارة ليموزين مع ح  أنا واذهب ،
تعرفني تشارلي روز أو أي شيء كان ذلك
مجرد جزء من طفولتنا
ثم في وقت لاحق عندما كنت في المدرسة الثانوية ، لذا كان
هذا مثل أواخر الثمانينيات وأوائل التسعينيات من القرن الماضي ،
كان لدينا زر ذعر في منزلنا وإذا
ضغطت عليه  مثل
أن تأتي الشرطة ونفعل تلك القصة التي كانت
عبارة عن مكتب والدي كانت حريق في مجلس الشيوخ
وكان هناك الكثير من التهديدات على حياته
من مثل الشعب اليهودي اليميني
، وقد كتبت هذه المرأة مقالاً في
مجلة نيويورك حول
وأطلق عليه اسم رجل عرفات في نيويورك والذي كان
عنوانًا فظيعًا وهو غاضب ومن
أشد ما ألتقي به
[تصفيق]
كيف لو كنت تريدني أن أصفه
طوال علاقته
بمنظمة التحرير الفلسطينية ، فكيف تكتب
العلاقة  بعض الأشياء لم
تنضم أبدًا إلى أي شيء بشكل كامل ، لذا
لم يكن أبدًا عضوًا في منظمة التحرير الفلسطينية ،
فهو عضو في المجلس الوطني الفلسطيني
لبعض الوقت ، لكنه كان دائمًا على بعد
خطوة واحدة لأنه شعر بأنه
مثقف وكان هذا هدفه
للبقاء خارج السياسة ، فإن
النساء في المنزل في الخلف بينما أفتقد hola ،
يمكننا إيقاف أي kuleana أكره أنه
هو وعرفات لم يتفقوا على معظم
الأشياء وفي نهاية حياته
لم تكن بحاجة إلى الإعجاب على وجه التحديد
قطع العلاقات مع
أمريكا
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] جدًا جدًا
ونهائيًا وياماها عرفات ماسيلون ،
ستقتلني فقط
هذه العائلة هي نصف جسد ساخن
ونعمي كانت تتمتع بصيف جميل جدًا
بصريًا المواد التي يمكن التحدث عنها و
الكثير من الخريطة - كينيدي يتمتع بصحة جيدة
يمكننا تغذيته بالزعيم آلان مولالي هذا
مطاردة الأعشاش القاتلة في باجا ، حيث
ستكون قابلة للغسل بشكل محموم ويمكن بهدوء
والنظافة عامل فيلم مختلف
مع حد يصعب على الطاقة كيف سيتم
بيع محمصة و
[موسيقى  ]
أنام في Hoonah annum في Hoonah وكذلك
إلى Huaraz إلى Hoonah
نعم maniel sake على أي حال
مضحك للغاية ما أحب المحامي الرحمة
ليكون في American Toa Lobo yogathon
الإنجليزية الإيطالية بشكل
متقن وآية الله فريديت ما يحب
عندما  hibari-sama في kupuna bream
sashimi aha حسنًا ، سيكون Phil في أو
بجانب الأسماك في نيويورك في نوع من
منطقة البحر الكاريبي الوطنية ولقطات أعلى ،
Philistine Canberra Hema من الألومنيوم ، ما الذي
سيفعله Edwards في بعض مستشفى
Gemma ،
يا انفتاحي الغيور الإستوني
وفير  من سلسلة الموت الرهيبة
شيفيلد توم في مزاج وطني ، أتمنى
أن تتأكد من أن كينيث
اختار أمي الدجاج التي حصلت والدتي على
طاقة إيجابية هيستيرية بيزيني ،
وهذا هو بالضبط كيف نحصل على هذا الاسم الدموي
إدواردز بالليمون تحت ساتين سينغ
[موسيقى]
ها هي  أرسل EMS 60s vasotec tear em basa Masotti a wide my mata
pasa
pasa la me toca Boca OC cable musta he
Sal لإلقاء musta هنا أبيض faux pas de
bourree Sal إلى Weymouth toka blocka pal
quasi gibbering
[تصفيق]
15 عامًا من الحواس وقال  قل
القس فيها كيف حاله
يتذكر اليوم كل ما قاله
ثبت أنه صحيح مثل كل
الأشياء التي تنبأ بها الآنسة بيلا ألين
ليفيل يكون سيريل ساجوار  o قنبلة وما
قاله كينيث لورا عقد شبكة أسورا يونغ كينغ
قد أرسل اللاعب المجهول في
قضية وظاهرة إليشا الحزن
وقد تم القبض عليها والشعاب المرجانية في الواقع
لديها معجب مضحك لم يكن يعرف ليزا بوب
لم تستطع أمي سعيدة شاردا تومين
بوتنر
أنا '  m آسف حذاء إدوارد كين الجديد ذو القدرات العالية
كان
سيداتي وسادتي وقحين السيد.  عرفات
رئيس المجلس التنفيذي
لمنظمة التحرير الفلسطينية
معالي السيد رابين رئيس
وزراء إسرائيل رئيس
الولايات المتحدة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نضيف أنه ربما قتل كيرسي
حلاً آخر قليل AMA و نوبل الآن
أم أخرى تقتلني  نعم ، يجب أن أتحدث
عن تاريخ الاختطاف الترادفي ، هل هي
تتصرف ، تخيل أن يكون
لديك بروفة ، نعم تعلمون عندما أنشر الأحذية أو الجليد
هناك كما تعلمون كما قلت ، هناك
ميمات على Instagram و Facebook أو
أشياء كتبها الناس
وأشاركها  الناس مثل والدك كان
مذهلاً ، لقد كان يحب التنبؤ بكل شيء ،
لذا هذه المرة وكان رائعًا جدًا
وحسن الحديث وأنا مثل طوال الوقت
الذي كان فيه على قيد الحياة ، لا أحد من بريتوني ، أي من
نفس الشيء الذي أملكه هو نيلسون مانديلا
بطريقة حيث  أنت معتاد على كره هذا
الرجل والآن أنت تقديسه لماذا
لأنه كان رجل مبادئ
وسلطة أخلاقية فيليسيا
وتفتقدك تفتقدك يا [ __ ] من نحن  هل يمكن أن
يضيف هذا بونيفا
حبهم للجامعة ، لقد كان حقيقيًا هنا
للسيراميك عزيزتي Muzzy nos domitius
بسهولة ،
شكرًا لك على Harrier res Elliott
ربما لا أتذكر ما هو التقويم الذي
لم أستطع حتى إلقاء نظرة على شعورك
بهزيمة جوني أنا  killin se ، إنه أمر غريب
لأن والدي كان صديقي المفضل
وأفتقده كثيرًا وأنا فخور
جدًا بكوني ابنته
وأي شخص يرى أي شيء في
داخلي يذكرهم بأنه شرف سواء كان
يدي فقط هناك شيء  باك
أو هذه هي الطريقة التي أعتقد أن حجم الأفكار أو
أي شيء أو الطريقة التي أكتب بها هو
شرف وسأظل دائمًا ، وأنا فخور جدًا
بأن أكون أصغر ، والأمر الصعب
بالطبع هو أنك تعلم أنه مؤلم
لأننا تحملنا الكثير من الانتقادات و  الكراهية
والطعن في الظهر بينما كان على قيد الحياة
والعديد من الفرص والعديد من الأشياء
التي حدثت لي ولأخي
كأطفال لا أريد حتى أن أذكرها
من حيث عدم رغبة أصدقائنا
في قضاء الوقت معنا أو أي شيء آخر
بسبب  ou  أبي ثم اتضح أن
كل ما كان عليه كان مثل
رجل واقعي للغاية يكاد يكون طوباويًا
ومثل الجميع مثل والدك
كان إنسانًا رائعًا ، يبدو من الظلم
أن هذا يعني أنه أمر لا يصدق أنه كان
سابقًا لعصره وأنا  أنا فخور جدًا
بذلك وأنا ساخن جدًا ولكني أيضًا بطريقة ما
لأن الناس ما زالوا ليسوا كذلك ، أعني أن
والدي كتب كتابًا بعنوان تغطية
الإسلام وماذا في عام 1979 أو شيئًا عن
كيفية تصوير وسائل الإعلام للإسلام والناس
ما زلت لا يبدو أنها اكتشفت هذا
الأمر وراء ، سأكون نعم ، أعتقد
أن الأمر يتعلق بالموضة ، يمكنك أن ترى أنك تعلم
أن الشخصية التي كنت أقوم بها ماجا قد فعلت لي فهدًا
موحلًا لم تكن وظيفتي من
أجلي لذلك أنا  لم أكن معتادًا على غنائها
، وعندما يأتي ذلك ، يكون الناس
دائمًا مثل يا إلهي ، ثم
أتفاجأ لأنني لا أعتقد أن
بعض المصرفيين الاستثماريين يجب أن يعرفوا من
والدي الذي تعرفه يسمي زملائي المواطنين
في هذا  ساعة القوات الأمريكية وقوات التحالف
في المراحل الأولى من
العمليات العسكرية ل  نزع سلاح العراق
لتحرير شعبه والدفاع عن العالم
من خطر جسيم بناءً على أوامر مني.
بدأت قوات التحالف بضرب
أهداف وأهمية عسكرية مختارة
لتقويض قدرة صدام حسين على
شن حرب ،
وهذه هي المراحل الأولى لما سيكون
حملة واسعة ومنسقة.
لا تتحدث إلى الكثير من المناطق
التي أعلم أنها كانت حركة حتى
الكاميرا اللانهائية له ، وقد تفاعلت مع Hodari
أن يكون القياس في حليف نار قابل للاستخدام
وأنت تقرأ متاحًا على بوش يساعد في
البقاء منخفضًا للهجوم الأولي ونعم كينيث
الصغير تعال هيلين في بلدي
إن الإنسانية الإنسانية لأبي وسينيا هي
الوحيدة وسأذهب إلى حد القول
المقاومة النهائية التي نواجهها ضد
الممارسات اللاإنسانية والقضاة الذين
يشوهون التاريخ البشري ، نحن اليوم
مدفوعون بالمجال الهائل المشجع
للفضاء السيبراني المفتوح لجميع المستخدمين
والطرق  لما حلمت به
الأجيال السابقة سواء من الطغاة أو
الأرثوذكس ، فإن الاحتجاجات العالمية
قبل بدء الحرب في الفن
لن تكون  كان ممكنًا
لولا وجود مجتمعات بديلة في
جميع أنحاء العالم يتم تنشيطها بواسطة
المعلومات البديلة وإدراكًا تامًا
لبيئة حقوق الإنسان
والدوافع التحررية التي تربطنا
معًا في هذا الكوكب الصغير ،
فالرغبة الإنسانية والإنسانية في التنوير
والتحرر ليست كذلك  تأجيلها بسهولة
على الرغم من قوة
المعارضة لها التي تأتي من رامسفيلد بن
لادن وشارون وبوش في هذا
العالم ، أود أن أصدق أن
كتابي "الاستشراق" كان له مكانة صغيرة
في الطريق الطويل والمتقطع غالبًا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق  ]
و mazurka الذي تشبيهًا لزجًا بأنه
إذا كان جيش ألفا ، فقد تم تسميته Rene Okawa
maharba Sidhu Mahalo le babila ، وكان
السيروتونين على الزجاجة المخروطية ، ميلاني
لاهيري ، فأنت تجرؤ على الشعور بالتعاسة أو ما في
Intuit يعيد توصيل nastran بسهولة ،
فأنت تمزح بشأن من هو Holly
فاصلة فضائية  لفتح الشب ليكون بؤرة تينا
إذا كنت تتحدث عن بعض الكلمات على
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]